[Music]
since the 1970s there have been at least
18 gangs within the los angeles county
sheriff's department
and they continue to brutalize and even
murder community members today
my name is cerise castle and i am a
journalist in the summer of 2020
i was working for a local radio station
here in los angeles
and i
was out covering the george floyd
rallies that were happening
across the country across the world i
was
shooting photos of people protesting
and
while i was doing that
two cars with police officers on them in
riot gear rolled into
the area where people had gathered and
they shot people with less lethal
munitions and
although i identified myself as press
i was shot and the resulting injuries
landed me in the hospital
a few days after that happened the los
angeles sheriff's department
killed a teenager
who was working at his job in the
compton area
very quickly after this young man was
killed his name is andres guardado
was reported that
his killing may have been part of a gang
initiation and there are some new
allegations against the deputy involved
in guardado's case who did not fire his
weapon civil rights attorneys accused
christopher hernandez of being part of
what some call a sheriff's department
click or gang while i was bedridden
i started researching the history of the
gangs in the los angeles county
sheriff's department
and i found out that
this dates back at least 50 years
i spent
six months
researching
deputy gangs within the los angeles
county sheriff's department
uh conservatively i estimate i read
about 100 000 pages of legal filings
and what i came away with was a 15 part
series
detailing
18 gangs that i was able to confirm
the existence of within the department
there are the little devils posse the
wayside whities the 2000 boys the three
thousand boys the jump out boys the
banditos the executioners the spartans
the cowboys the rattlesnakes and the
tasmanian devils
they have killed 19 people all of whom
were men of color several of whom were
in a mental health crisis when they were
killed
government from the
county level the state level and the
federal level
has known about this issue
since the early 1990s
and no significant action
policy change has been brought forth
so let's do a quick run through of the
gangs of the los angeles sheriff's
department all of them have stuff in
common you usually have official gang
tattoos a hand signal and a way to join
usually by shooting or killing a
civilian or doing something like
falsifying paperwork
these are
1990s
their sign was having their middle
fingers crossed to create a w for white
the linwood vikings the vikings were a
gang based out of the linwood station
their tattoo was of a viking and their
hand sign was an l made with the thumb
and index finger for linwood
and they were one of the most powerful
and most violent gangs a lot of their
members became leaders in the department
the three thousand boys the three
thousand boys were based out of the
men's central jail in downtown la the
three thousand boys are particularly
violent because that's where the
department would transfer deputies
convicted of crimes to keep them away
from the public
the jump out boys the jump out boys
operated across the county in the
operations safe streets unit their
tattoo was of a skeleton with glowing
red eyes holding a revolver in the dead
man's hand a popular poker holding among
law enforcement officers they kept their
manifesto in a notebook
the regulators out of the century
station you have the regulators who
allegedly have many members working in
department leadership
the executioners at the compton station
you have the executioners their tattoo
is of a skeleton with a nazi helmet
holding an assault rifle black people
and women are not allowed to join the
gang
the banditos the banditos operate mainly
out of the east la station and their
tattoo is of a skeleton wearing a
sombrero with a smoking revolver and a
sheriff's badge
they have a culture of working backwards
arresting or shooting civilians and
coming up with probable cause later by
planting and manufacturing evidence
there are others like the rattlesnakes
the pirates and the buffalo soldiers
that we know a lot less about
[Music]
[Music]
anyway i'm here today at a rally
two year anniversary of the killing of
paul raya 18 year old young man at a
traffic stop by hector salvedra
who's east l.a sheriff deputy
who
was a prospect
for the
deputy
sheriff gang los banditos
now how do i know that
because two deputies
who work here
were uh interviewed on national tv la
sheriff deputy hector savidrasoto is he
a prospect for the banditos yes he is
he's a prospect
paul ray is my son he was murdered on
june 27 2019
um it was a
supposed to be a traffic stop
um
they
pulled them out of their cars with guns
um when they were cushioning
where they're getting pulled over they
were scared because they didn't know why
they were getting pulled over
and they're getting pulled over with
guns that you know to their heads and
being told that
if they move they're gonna shoot their
[ __ ] heads off
um they pulled the driver out of the car
and um when they pulled my son out
they're going to handcuff my son and i
know my son was feared for his life he
just from childhood you know growing up
seen me harassed before
um he ran he didn't even get four feet
away when hector savadra shot on
multiple times in the back
paul's father was actually killed by
sheriff's deputies so he
grew up his whole life being afraid of
this deputy gang so when they asked him
to get out of the car naturally he was
afraid so he attempted to exit that
interaction which is
perfectly within his right since he was
not the driver
unfortunately
savadra
pursued paul and
shot him in the back multiple times
right here and paul died
the two deputies that killed anthony
vargas were also prospects for the east
l.a sheriff's gang anthony vargas was
shot by sheriff deputy nicolas perez and
sheriff deputy jonathan rojas are they
also part of the banditos gang or
prospects for the banditos prospects yes
they're prospects how do you know
you know just personal conversations
with them and them saying that was one
of their main goals to be a part of this
gang
uh august 12th of 2018 my nephew um he
had attended a barbecue you know he was
just
following what he always did you know
whenever there was a barbecue he showed
up took his rub he thought it was the
best rub so hey get it out there right
he took it and um
you know that was the last time that was
the last day that we we've seen it was
august 11th
there was a robbery call that had went
into the east l.a sheriff's department
where an individual had said that they
had their 12 watch stolen they gave a
description of an individual 30 to 40
years old over six feet tall
um
you know it fit nothing of anthony's
description wearing a completely
different colored shirt than my nephew
had on
you know two deputies from the sally
sheriff's department were
you know servicing the area at the time
and they saw my nephew walking down
one of the fire paths on his way home
and they you know targeted him
my nephew was punched in his head
multiple times punched in his ribs by
these deputies
um you know before falling to his knees
where he was shot at 16 times it was
just like bam bam bam bam bam bam bam
continuous shots one man shot and killed
by los angeles county sheriff's deputies
investigators say the young man did have
a gun on him but they're not sure if he
was a part of the robbery anthony was
not known to carry a gun on him
he slept in a room with my mom which is
his grandma he slept directly across
from my seven-year-old niece after she
was seven years old at the time anthony
was not known to carry a gun
you know he was not known to carry
weapons he was you've never seen him no
never
if you get in a shooting that's a
definite brownie point and according to
these deputies to justify those
shootings they plant weapons on the
people they stop there's been multiple
occasions where they say hey we got a
guy that has a gun and he's running from
us in reality that person never had a
gun and they would say oh it was a
phantom gun it was something that really
wasn't there so you have personally
witnessed that yes and we started
reading the d a report and matching them
with you know other things that we found
on our own
which includes like you know the
like the autopsy report you know
we found out through forensics that the
gun that they're saying my nephew had on
him had absolutely no dna on it
none of my nephew's dna and i find it
strange because these these deputies are
saying that my nephew had the gun in his
hand and he was like an imminent threat
to them
but if he was holding a gun in his hand
there would have been fingerprints on
the gun
immediately after i released the first
part of the series i began receiving
death threats
i regularly receive
threatening messages on my social media
i receive
phone calls
from people threatening my
life i
have my loved ones have received these
messages as well
the sheriff of los angeles county has
instructed
anyone that i reported on to personally
sue me
and
when i attempted to attend a press
conference
featuring the sheriff's department i was
detained
why
[Laughter]
i think the sheriff's department
has decided to target me
since i released the series
we started like
just
finding [ __ ]
and everything we would find out about
anthony or about the sheriff's
department we would come out and talk
and the more we would come out and talk
the cops would pass by
the house
and
they would park on the corner of our
street which they still do to this time
they would park in the corner of our
house and they would sit in our car and
they would eat their lunch
and you know there's a corner store from
where
our family residence is so the kids will
walk to the store
and they can't even walk to the store
because they see the sheriff's
department right there because they know
what they did to anthony and these are
kids
under the age of like 15.
[Music]
[Music]
deputy art gonzalez is a documented hero
a former marine who became a deputy
rewarded by the l.a county sheriff's
department with the medal of valor in
2018 for saving the life of a
four-year-old boy the time is 10 59 and
we are on the record
now he's sounding the alarm of a group
of 15 officers inside the compton
station with matching tattoos allegedly
known as the executioners
i now
call them a gang because that's what
gangs do
they beat up
other people deputy gonzalez
he's afraid for his safety right now he
also reports that graffiti appeared at
the station entrance
art is a rat and that was placed at the
keypad to get into the parking lot so
that's the most visible place in the
entire station his lawyer says he's now
on leave from the department and in fear
for his life
in addition to having to hire security
guards to go with me when i
do my job
i've had to start wearing a bulletproof
vest um
many of these death threats are credible
and i've been told by people inside the
department that
i should be careful
so
i invested
in this this is a bulletproof vest
i
yeah this guy comes with me
very often
why do you keep doing it
i continue to report on this story
because
no one else really is
and
seeing
the
closure i suppose that i'm able to bring
to families um
you know oftentimes they had suspected
for years that
their loved one had been killed by a
deputy gang member
and i can come along and confirm that
and i've also seen
my reporting make a very real difference
in some of
the ongoing cases
just recently
the
democratic party of los angeles county
uh passed a resolution asking for the
sheriff to resign and now that
you know everything's came out like
there's a complete you know turn and
like i can't tell you how it feels to
like see the tide turn
you know like it's [ __ ]
groundbreaking and it's like it shows
you the progress that's being made you
know it just makes you want to keep
pushing more and more because when we
were fighting back then like that push
now has come it's come even further and
it's just like it [ __ ] it encourages
you the sheriff alex villanueva the
lead gang member of la county he's a
bandito himself
this is 10 3 000 boys deputy mark romero
is one of them and now today i believe
he's a homicide sheriff but he's a 3 000
boy underneath
uh we're out here spreading the word
everyone's saying it google lasd gangs
everyone should be uh tagging their
neighborhood with google lasd games
google lasd gangs [ __ ] the banditos plus
sheriff villanueva [ __ ] lasd as a
organization by the way when you're done
googling 40 cops uh google los angeles
sheriff department gangs okay lasd games
we know about your gangs we're telling
our people to google lasd gangs and
we're coming for your asses and then
there's as another woman therese
who has been uh putting together a
series about the gangs in the uh
sheriff's department so i'm going to
take a look at all of this as these
investigations are going on
we have video proof we have pictures
we've taken them to the sheriff's
department we've called the clc meetings
we've done what we had to do and
nothing's gotten done
it's unacceptable we will send a clear
message to the la county sheriff's
department that you clean your house
you get your house in order and we will
surely help you do that you have
executioners you have gangs in your own
house keep going out there and just keep
fighting and keep exposing them for what
they are and what they're doing because
it's
you know their reign of terror isn't
going to stop unless we put a stop to it
so that's
we're not going away anytime soon you
know like we
we're here to stay
you